28 year old right-hander who last took
the ball on tuesday against tampa bay
and was very effective allowed three
earned runs over five innings did not
factor in the decision in a yankee win
that took extra innings and ever since
coming back from the alternate training
side at the end of april alex he's been
pretty good he has been pretty good he
has electric stuff and people hitters
will chase all night long he has a fast
ball a curveball and a change
strike one is most important and get in
that 96 percent tile of chase one man
down for
alex ferdugo swung on a drive to right
field indeed this one is long gone
into the bleachers tremendous home run
for alex verdugo and the red sox lead at
one nothing number eight for alex's 25th
rbi and no doubter oh did he crush it
there was no yankee stadium
cheap home run he
really got it all
108 miles an hour
446 feet
he's locked in right now joe wouldn't it
be nice to have a little traffic on the
bases ahead of him that was an absolute
blast tough assignment today 33 year old
veteran garrett richards has been very
good as a red sox well garrett richards
is now looking to dial up a double play
ball something he's had a lot of success
in doing and that sets up gary sanchez
with the bases loaded in one gun
sanchez rips the ball into the left
field corner
that'll do damage judge scores easily
torres right behind him he hit a line
drive off the left field wall a two-run
double for sanchez and the yankees take
a 2-1 lead labor had one of the four
straight hits in the first inning that
led to the two runs against richards
1-2 pitch grounders shortstop bogarts to
gonzalez for one and the relay to
dalbeck is in time to double them up
big time hot shot and a great play by
bogarts to start the twin keller two
downs 56 grounded into double plays by
the yankees
sanders got three hits in 10 at-bats in
this series but he is not himself at the
moment swung on and lying deep down the
left-field line and duhar in the run has
to play it on a hop in the corner he
fires in towards second the throw is in
time
hottie i like that miguel and duhar
he was deep in the left field corner
through a one hop strike domingo gives
him the high sign
and easily out
was bogus well that was a big play by
andura
so they're loaded up for aaron judge
swung on grounded up the middle grabbed
his second flip the short is in time for
the out the run scores and duhar
gardner goes to third
judge on the
field his choice gets an rbi
that's his 32nd the yankees take a 3-1
lead two great plays here one on the
front end and then the bounce pass and
bogart turns himself into a first
baseman
excellent play by bogarts first and
third and keeps the double play in order
here's a 2-2
and it's line
foul down the right field
we've got our mvp fan of the game
already this is one of the foul balls
from giovanni orchella
why you bring your glove
give that fan a contract
you remember that call
one gun now for alex verdugo who's homer
in the first stands as the lone boston
run of the game
one pitch herman gets him to fly to left
i don't think ferdugo felt like that
ball was going to be in in play
let alone fair yeah sometimes you hit a
ball maddie you think is
in the stands for a foul ball he
absolutely thought this was a foul ball
well first pitching change of the game
domingo herman gone after five and two
thirds he exits with only one earned run
on his tally and responsible for a base
runner he does leave with a two run lead
and hands the ball off to left-hander
lucas litki hoping to get out of this
little mini find with a runner aboard
litki pitched on friday worked an inning
in two thirds his number has been called
often of late making his 21st appearance
of the year now ogart's with two down is
at second base pevers is 274 with two
home runs against lefties the pitch
[Applause]
is looking out at lucas saying who are
you
3-1 yankees after six it'll be marwin
who's had a big weekend in new york he
does have a flare for the dramatic
oh one pitch to marvin gonzalez a high
drive into the left-field corner and
back and it's gone
and this one is tied
marwin gonzalez another big swing in new
york two-run big fly and we are tied at
three
another dramatic swing from marwin he's
had quite a series of men on base
a couple of big doubles now a two run
homer second of the year the fourth
given up by luki this season
a mistake pitch
to gonzalez
into the short part of left field
gonzales last home run
on april 17th
in a big one for the red sox oh and one
to torres
pitch is high in the air into left field
not hit well verdugo dives and makes the
play
that was off the end of the bat judge
came to second race back to first what a
grab by verdugo a full out
belly-flopping dive and he
retires torres for the first down of the
seventh as he did in the ninth inning
last night opening the unit
over the third christian arroyo go ahead
run at third base and one gone hogarth
swings and sends a ball out to center
field that'll be more than enough to
score arroyo with the go ahead run
xander bogarts comes through for boston
again
made the time runs on base frazier has a
single lead to right field stanton to
pinch it here he's one two pitch swing
and a miss he doubt him on a slider down
and away he missed that ball by a foot
what a job by josh taylor the yankees
are three outs away
from suffering a home sweep to their
sworn mortal enemies he represents the
winning run with one out one on here in
the last of the night line a basement in
the left field and it's toward the line
judge goes around second he heads for
third they're gonna wave him the relay
throw won't be made judge scores
so here's odor torres is the man of the
moment he's the winning run oh my
goodness barnes gets a call on a
curveball to send this game into extra
innings
wow
phil nevin came out of the yankee dugout
immediately to take issue with the call
and was ejected that is a very fiery guy
i like that i think the yankees need
this second third two down and will
bogarts do what he did his last time up
come up with a huge swing a sac fly in
the eighth put the red sox ahead
bogart's drives one into left field
toward the gap no one gets it vasquez
scores dulbeck right behind him two run
hit for bogarts and the red sox leading
six to four in the tenth so the yankees
now have the charring runs on base with
no one out swinging a ground ball back
to phillips he pauses throws to second
gonzalez glove throws to first in time
double play tyler wade making his first
played appearance of the game
representing the last chance for new
york tonight grounded weekly up the
first baseline
gonzales throws to first it goes away
scoring his outdoor wade goes to second
base with a game now six five here's le
mayhew a base it with wade's speed
should tie the game
lemay here with a bouncing ball
smothered by gonzalez throw to first in
time to get him and this one's done
they sweep a three-game series at yankee
stadium for the first time in 10 years